what's up everyone welcome back to
gamespot if you did not hear recently we
announced that we are moving our live
show the lobby from Tuesday's to
wednesdays at 11am pacific we're doing
this because we want you to be more
involved we want you to be able to play
these games on Tuesdays and they come
out and then converse with us rather
than just hear us talk about them so
tomorrow at 11am wednesday the 18 so
we're going to be talking primarily
about the nintendo switch what do you
think about the launch title do you
think about the release date what do you
think about the pricing we're going to
talk about our thoughts but I want to
hear yours so for the time being before
we set up a specific email address tweet
it gamespot hashtag the lobby just so we
can kind of organize it what do you
think about all the new details what do
you think of the launch titles what more
does Nintendo need to do to get you
involved I'm really looking forward to
season the lobby I can't wait to hang
out with you more I will see you
tomorrow at 11am have a good night